i'm not happy about today's video
okay but i'm starting it by just giving
you guys
a word from our sponsor which is
me on this channel guys don't forget to
pump the coin
zilla don't invest in anything it's the
coin you literally just have to
subscribe
today we're talking about a 3.6 billion
with the b uh scam that happened with
the crypto exchange called
africt there really is only one reaction
you're gonna have when you hear about
this
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
guys i'm your host
coffeezilla and yes another day
another scam i'm wondering like are we
doing the same video is it groundhog day
like we're just doing the same video
over and over and over again
but look hey you guys keep getting
scammed i will keep covering it i don't
know
did i not dodge that i almost got hit
dude basically we got a mystery on our
hands today
these south african crypto exchange
brothers vanished
and so does 3.6 billion dollars in
bitcoin i mean what's the mystery guys
like i wonder what happened when the two
guys who ran the exchange
and 3.6 billion dollars vanished oh
where where could it have gone
i'm sorry to laugh it's it's so sad
what's going on right now these guys ran
a thing called afrocrypt
and before you say stephen this is
insensitive like be respectful
listen you've got to see their
promotional video it's
so bad how did people put 3.6 billion
dollars into this
let's watch we always keep marching
forward and explore this is their only
video by the way sorry
real quick okay bring the unknown world
we always seek for innovation to achieve
excellence
ai or artificial intelligence offers our
future infinite opportunities
but what happens when ai comes across a
fund
how brilliant would it be afrocrypt was
created by a team of seasoned
technologists
and experienced finance professionals
that recognized the opportunity for
algorithmic trading within the digital
asset markets
the result is the afrikrypt ai driven
trading platform
this is every corporate presentation
just sort of
mashed into one you get the stock music
you've got the
poorly animated uh graphics a
i is a cutting ed the robo-voice
cutting-edge technology
that we will use to make you money it is
the future i am sure which is why if you
put your money with
us you are sure to succeed success
follows success
y'all fell for this wow dude
again oh this is a hard one for me
because i'm like
guy if you fell for this what
and it gets so much worse that's the
worst part of this it's just like it's
gonna get gradually worse
so basically these guys uh these two
brothers
started up afrocrypt and it was a
the world's first south african crypto
exchange
that um had ai trading on it or
something they managed to
accumulate 3.6 billion to bitcoin and
then in
april they suddenly froze accounts
because um
well i'll just read it to you this is an
email everyone got
dear client we regret to inform you that
uh due to a recent breach in our system
client accounts
client wallets and nodes were all
compromised
getting hacked is the new crypto version
of the dog ate my homework
it's like hey i know it's supposed to
have your stuff ready today but the dog
ate it
and whenever you hear that there's a
there's like a 50 50 chance they
actually got hacked
or just the founders are running with
your money that's true so they say
it has caused afrocrypt to halt
operations
okay that's weird but this is the worst
part they say
we urge all clients to be patient as we
attempt to resolve the situation
at hand it's understandable that clients
may
proceed with the legal route but we ask
clients to please
acknowledge that this will only delay
the recovery process
they're literally telling you don't go
to lawyers
don't go to the cops dude it could delay
it you're
sincerely and it's the ceo amir kg
but now it's time to meet the team guys
who are these
kg brothers that ran off with everyone's
money well
raheez is the older one he's 20 years
old you heard that right
the ceo of a crypto exchange
entrusted with 3.6 uh billion dollars
in crypto assets is 20 years old that's
how old the guy is
right okay sure we're in la la land now
okay whatever
amir kg he's 17 which nice beard
if you really are 17. from one guy to
another nice
but in all seriousness we're supposed to
believe these uh
young whipper had 3.6 billion dollars
and people thought they were going to
run it well
according to one article the reason some
of these investors believed it
is because they were told that raw ease
is a childhood prodigy
who was able to create a trading
algorithm that allowed them
to trade while they attended school wow
never heard that one before childhood
prodigy turns out to be a massive
scammer and we've heard from these
supposed childhood prodigies before who
turn out to be scammers like stefan
keane you guys remember that guy the
ponzi schemer
so anyways they claim that they are
hacked but meanwhile nobody can find
them
and they seem to have run away
understandably people got their lawyers
involved
and apparently the court high court i
guess in south africa
told the brothers the afrocrypt brothers
that they had to give back the bitcoin
and they had until july 19th to argue
against the liquidation
instead it just looks like they ran away
and not only did they run away
they also just shut the website down i
mean they're not even trying to pretend
this isn't a scam anymore
and they moved these supposed hacked
bitcoins
of course they moved after the uh they
couldn't find these guys these kg
brothers
and they moved it through what's called
tumblers and mixers
guys this is very interesting so part of
crypto that makes it difficult to like
steal money is the fact that well
everything's in the blockchain
so supposedly you can trace it right the
problem is is there's
this new innovation called these mixers
i guess it's not that new but basically
how it works is that you send
your basically dirty money bitcoin into
this massive
pot of other people's bitcoin and you
get out
to another address bitcoin that may not
be yours but it's like
similar to the amount so like let's say
ice in in 20 bitcoin and let's say
they're
sort of marked we know those are still
in bitcoin i'm gonna get out
a bunch of unstolen bitcoin and that
bitcoin is going to get washed somewhere
else
so it basically think of putting a bunch
of money into a like a dryer or
something it all tumbles around and you
take
your amount of money back out so you're
probably not going to have the same
dirty bills
it's a really shady way of laundering
dirty money
just an interesting quirk of this case
that i thought was worth mentioning
so that's basically the story in a
nutshell now i did go to where they said
they were located
in south africa well no i didn't go i
went to google maps and of course you
can't find
any building with their name on it
anywhere here it just looks like some
bogus address here
they're at the pharmaceutical society of
south africa
okay they also said they had an
international address in china
of course nowhere to be found there
either for now
sadly i think most people's money is
gone
um let this be a lesson guys hey
[Music]
watch coffeezilla okay none of my fans
would have ever fallen for this
and nobody should be falling for this
we've seen the same mo
over and over again right sketchy
exchange pops up
nobody's heard of the founders before or
they have very little to recommend them
people put way too much money with it
they don't store their money in cold
wallets
it gets hacked and then the founders
disappear
but anyways that's it for now we'll
follow up in the story if we have any
new developments
and thanks for watching hey
you took my money away
you said that it was safe but i'm loved
and i don't feel okay